they're young and they're fed up a
funeral procession at the de hecho
refugee camp near Bethlehem these young
people are often called generation post
Oslo yet the Oslo Accords never brought
peace and never ended the Israeli
occupation these people want a new
Intifada in uprising janessa where are
people living under occupation for 60
years a crime has been committed against
us it was really just a question of time
before all this went off all these
settlements the numerous checkpoints the
wall we have no hope of living a normal
life this funeral procession is for a
young Palestinian from the camp who was
shot during protests against the Israeli
army there are protests here almost
every day Palestinians also criticized
their own government calling it an
Israeli puppet incapable of independence
and they say the tension surrounding the
al-aksa mosque and the Temple Mount are
further reasons for the situation the
mood and Jerusalem's Old City is
extremely tense security forces are
everywhere only a few shops and the
Muslim Quarter are open today this is a
protest not an Intifada for an Intifada
you need people who are organized
involved what we're seeing here is a
burst of emotion from young people that
did not follow his shop is right behind
a Jewish settlement a young Palestinian
stabbed several Israelis nearby two men
died a woman and a child were wounded
the beginning of a spate of attacks
mostly committed by lone young
Palestinians security has been beefed up
here in the old city to almost
unprecedented levels but it doesn't make
people feel more secure on both sides
the new checkpoints around the Arab
quarter bring only a limited sense of
security I need my mean my mom for
having a dialogue and for giving them
the right celeb but it just can't be
that they come here and kill Jews with
knives movie own sake name you would
need in the old city devout young
Israelis aren't scared off by the
violence
the contrary the butter kind of come
here to show solidarity this is our turf
and we won't let anything drive us away
from here even if it's not totally safe
we're staying here for eternity long
live the Jewish people but what's
supposed to bring security for some
means more checkpoints and restrictions
for others who also live here constant
security checks with young Palestinians
considered especially suspicious this
young man lives in the old city he says
the controls are humiliating leno an
intervention if you're an Arab or Muslim
then you're out of long lesson from your
doorstep to Damascus Gate you'll get
controlled at least five times I'm not
about homeless model whether it's an
uprising in intifada or a wave of
violence for many this is what results
when there's no prospect of a political
solution